we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p now this is
a voicemail about twenty twenty most
election cycles this would be a
perfectly reasonable question to answer
in the direct way that the person wants
me to answer it in 2020 we interpret
this question differently take a listen
to this and you'll know what i mean
yeah my question is what do you think is
going to be the big deciding issues for
swing states like Iowa in the twenty
twenty elections and what candidate best
champion those issues be them democrat
or republican so in a normal election
year I would say oh it's going to be
health care and national security and
that's going to be that is not the
analysis in 2020 in 2020 we have a
situation where this is going to
ultimately be an election that comes
down to turnout and that is going to be
effectively decided by what is the
perceived state of the American economy
in 2020 health care plans we know at
this point Trump promised since 2015 a
big beautiful health care plan it's not
happening it didn't happen and even if
Trump got something passed it would be
terrible we know that most Democrats are
now on board with some version of
Medicare for all Joe Biden wants to work
around the edges and make some
improvements to Obamacare okay but we
understand what it is it is not
ultimately going to be the
difference-maker it is going to be what
is turnout from both people who voted
for Trump in 2016 people who did not
vote for Trump in 2016 and people who
didn't vote at all in 2016 are we going
to be able to turn out our base or are
we not going to be able to do that and a
lot of it will just be what is the
perceived strength of the American
economy tariffs will be a part of it the
stock market will be a part of it
employment rates will be a part of it
and it is that is the issue so to speak
but ultimately it is a referendum on
Donald Trump even more you know I think
back to in elections I've covered or
actually this was before the show even
started but even in elections I paid
attention to closely when george w bush
was up for re-election in
for it was effectively a referendum on
George W Bush including on the
disastrous economy at the time and on
the Iraq war it is difficult to remove
an incumbent president the incumbency
the presidency has a significant power
of incumbency and ultimately george w
bush was reelected if I recall correctly
because of something like a hundred or a
hundred and fifty thousand votes in Ohio
that went his way instead of John
Kerry's way I think that 2020 is even
more of a referendum on the president's
then 2004 was on george w bush and
ultimately i appreciate the question i
could rattle off listen you know health
care is more important than gun safety
people tend to vote more on jobs plans
than they do on foreign policy we could
do all of that stuff but ultimately that
is not the way that this election is
going to go down and this is why it is
so important so important that we turn
the bass out it's got to happen that is
what this is going to ultimately hinge
on i would hope that in you mentioned
Iowa in Iowa farmers are getting crushed
and in Iowa you may actually see the
election hinge on do farmers and people
who know farmers which is a lot of
Iowans recognize that Donald Trump's
trade war and tariffs have been what has
so significantly damaged the economy in
Iowa and hurt so many farmers I don't
know the answer to that a lot of them
say they're angry with Trump but they
don't seem to be saying I'm not voting
for Trump which are two very different
things
recognizing that Trump did a bad is not
the same as saying I as a lifelong
Republican farmer I'm going to vote for
a Democrat that is much harder to get
people to do we've got a great bonus
show for you today
Beto or Roarke is blasting Breitbart
after ejecting their reporter this is
going to be an interesting one I will
also talk about a Japanese public
transport idea of invisible ink stank
ink stamps to identify gropers on public
transit and also we will talk about
Montana men who lied about military
service who have been ordered to wear I
am a liar signs in public is this
logical is this an adult punishment or
is this
something that is just a bit too
childish and that we should not be
pursuing as part of our legal systems
actions all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show become a member at
join pakman.com to get instant access or
become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show